parce que moi j'estime que déjà je suis
assez grande pour savoir ce que je fais
et je n'ai pas besoin de me calquer à
quelqu'un et je déconseille aux gens de
ce que de vivre en se calquant sur les
autres ça c'est n'importe quoi et les
jeunes pour moi déjà ça doit être
interdite en dessous de 18 ans déjà
c'est une interdiction pour moi mais ces
fermes il n'y a aucune de mes filles qui
fera date chirurgie ou quoi que ce soit
ni des injections avant 18 ans et encore
parce que comme il le dit docteur s'est
vraiment même en tout fin à partir de 20
25 ans les infections 25 ans je pense
c'est 27 à peu près voir mais la
trentaine par contre le botox oui c'est
préventive ça évite des rides du lion de
sochaux faire la différence entre des
injections saint jean louis alors la
maaf mason vous faisait qu'elle a joué
depuis 24 ans vous avez fait quoi vous
j'ai fait la poitrine le nez deux fois
l'élève le coin des yeux botox au front
et des facettes
un beau palmarès et vous sentez mieux
maintenant je me sens très bien
c'est vrai vous étiez mais c'était pour
faire comme les autres ne sais pas ce
que vous étiez où vous sentiez vous anti
pas belle non c'est merci c'est quand on
vous voit c'est rosie à la violence il
assuré les chalets je pense qu'elle
était déjà très belle non je ressemblais
à merci mais j'ai fait ça juste parce
que ça me permet de me sentir mieux dans
mon corps et je les fais de manière
réfléchie
bien que j'étais jeune quand j'ai
commencé mais quel âge et 24 ans j'avais
j'avais 19 ans la première opération
damon était mon complexe mais après
avoir déroulé sur ce qui se passe dans
les urnes
c'est habitez vous en avez donc drame
est prévue ben je n'ai pas l'intention
de m'arrêter tout de suite tant que
j'aurai déjà voulu me gêne c'est
pourquoi j'ai envie de refaire mes
mollets est très complexe et or mes
jambes du goudron parce qu'on fait des
mollets mais lors je pensais que l'air
du temps c'était pouvoir disposer de son
corps comme on l'entend et j'estime que
c'est pas dangereux pour la santé par
mois que de fumer ou où vous le savez
roguez de faire des vacances là dedans
alors parce que ça coûte cher
non pas tout mon argent mais une bonne
partie se passe de mon argent de la
manière dont je le veux donc gestion que
et vos parents ils vouent leur avait
demandé leur avis avant de faire toutes
ces opérations pas du tout je demande
toujours la vie de mes parents
mais voyez vous un moment c'est comme si
vous allez acheter des petits écoliers
chez pensez vous en fait tout le temps
non j'en fais pas tout le temps mais il
est immense et mon corps et qu' ils
n'ont pas d'une part aucune - à plus ou
moins 2 par an vous n'avez pas peur que
ça devienne une sorte d'addiction c'est
à dire que puisque de toute façon par
essence personne n'est parfait et tant
mieux que vous cherchez cette perfection
et deux roues sans jamais pardon de vous
ça passe et que donc vous chercher cette
perfection et que vous ne la petite
teigne et jamais donc mais donc
continuer cette quête incessante et
chaque année retournées sur la table
d'opération est donc ça me procure une
satisfaction et que ça me fait me sentir
mieux dans ma peau je vois pas le
alors après si je peux me permettre sur
mason franchement ça ne se voit pas du
tout oui mais on sait que c'est très
bien fait parce que j'ai un super
chirurgien qui rament dire non quand je
vais vraiment vous c'est réussi on va
pas se mentir et maïsano bien où elle
prévient c'est à dire que vous le dites
sur vos réseaux que la plupart de vos
photos sont retouchées avec photoshop
parce que les jeunes y a le syndrome
snapshot tous veulent ressembler un fils
mais aussi aux influenceurs et la mode
de cette bouche que vous détestez série
ça a été lancé par kylie il ya une
recrudescence après dans le monde entier
et on veut ressembler aux influenceurs
mais c'est une chimère on peut pas
ressembler à quelque chose qui n'existe
pas et au moins maïssane prévient de ça
que toutes les photos sont photoshopée